wendy williams won't be putting anyone
in the hot seat for a little while
longer and we've got a lot to talk about
the wendy williams show announced the
titular host's hiatus will continue all
the way to early march this means wendy
will have been away from her talk show
for six months and counting the break's
been explained as a medical leave of
absence
wendy i know you're watching right now
on behalf of myself the panel your
co-host we love you and can't wait to
have you back in that perfect show
wendy's largely stayed out of the public
eye since her show returned in the fall
and tabloids continue to speculate over
her health and mental state
[Music]
still wendy seemed to be in good spirits
just weeks ago when her son shared this
rare clip of his mom treating herself to
breakfast in bed but back to what's
going on with her show guest hosts will
continue to fill in for the outspoken
star and many of them are familiar faces
there's so many hot topics so little
time comedian michael rappaport steps in
for the first week of february he's
hosted a few times already as has sherry
shepherd who returns later in the month
i got some good news
hip hop icons fat joe and remy ma will
be back on the stage too while bevy
smith and terence j will make their
debuts as co-hosts
so why is wendy's show working the way
it is here's what we know in september
the talker revealed wendy tested
positive for covid19 pushing the program
september 20th season premiere date to
october 4th i said what
what wendy's premiere was then postponed
again this time to october 18th when
guest hosts first began filling in
whitney cummings leah remini and
michelle visage you know i say if you're
a windy fan then you're gonna support
who's there to help her show carry on
right exactly until she comes back after
a couple of weeks back on the air the
show announced that wendy was still
struggling with health issues due to her
graves disease and thyroid condition my
thyroid my hyperthyroid is attached also
to graves disease
graves disease
squeezes the muscles behind your
eyeballs in november the 57-year-old tv
personality posted a lengthy message to
instagram which kicked off with her
signature phrase
i'm doing okay let's get started it's
time for hot topic and continued quote i
miss you all as everyone knows my health
has been a hot topic i'm making progress
but it's just one of those things that's
taking longer than we expected i'm a
woman of a certain age and i know enough
to listen to my doctors and will return
to my purple chair as soon as we all
agree i'm ready and before she wrapped
it all up she gave a special thanks to
her fans quote i have heard your prayers
and comments and feel all the love
you are everything to me i love spending
my mornings with you all and i'm doing
everything i can to get back to work but
right now wendy has to focus on wendy
[Music]
you